ciao ragazzi allora per i miei 200 mila
iscritti
volevo fare qualcosa un po più da
youtube si vede in giro tipo mi chiedete
anche spesso il do my life
ecco c'è un piccolo problema ma non so
disegnare niente c'è una riga non ha
soprattutto il merito come posso fare
raccontarvi non so tipo degli episodi
della mia vita senza disegnare con le
vecchie care foto ok allora questo è il
primo staresti datato 16 7 90 un'estate
caldissima nel quale marina tra acque
passiamo ai periodo musicista prima il
piano poi il violino e poi la chitarra
elettrica sapete quanti strumenti so
suonare adesso 0
passiamo alle foto con i primi vip
marina incontrabili per strada abbiamo
qui da robin hood
abbiamo il patrigno e c'è anche se non
sbaglio miss moda ecco queste sono le
prime i primi incontri marina quel mondo
dei vip è il primo trono di marina ai
denti era passiamo al periodo di tour
gico tour gico marina eccolo si avvicinò
alla chiesa ammessa la rifugi a piccanti
faceva così come lo è stato ancora
laudato si mi signore loro dato si mi
signore
poi c'è maria con la bibbia
sempre nel periodo liturgica moria alla
cresima che ha una fasciatura che non si
sapeva diventare suora o vuole smettere
proprio il retour gico è finito antica
del tuo cibo infatti passiamo non l'ho
scritto il post non so come chiamarlo
questo periodo chiamiamole transizione
ecco anzi no costerà periodo delle delle
acconciature la mia prima procedura
elegante
raffinate e di classe la definirei basic
passiamo al codini che alternavo alla
mezza coda me la facevo spesso mi
sentivo molto chi li usa di sailor moon
ed era tutto molto top e lì sono stati
naturali 90 e non so cos'è erano volete
il gol facebook sentivo molto [ __ ] e qui
non so come chiamano fa sapere dopo
averla linee come lo chiamiamo questo
periodo un po alternativo un po
ribellione già iniziava la ribellione
marina ha sempre avuto una grande
passione per il cibo in particolare le
schifezze marina che spegne 2 candeline
catherine su una torta più grossa di lei
maria che si ingozza sì il col dito il
cibo in bocca senza motivo pasticcini
zucchero filato
insomma perché c'era anche qualcosa di
salutare nella mia dieta infatti che non
maggio dovuta un periodo molto teen la
teenager o faccia finta di farmi una
foto e non rendermene conto ma i soci di
una foto e marina alle periodo
dimensione danza ero patita di amici il
sogno era fare la ballerina poi si è
cambiato un po il mood
ecco a proposito del periodo ballerina
abbiamo marina che ballava al flamenco
maria vestita da flamenca era con me
come ben sapete sono meta spagnole
quindi fin da piccola mi
furono regalati questi fantastici
vestiti con cui prezzi chiavola seriana
e qui invece l'evoluzione insomma una
dancing queen vero capodanno mi ricordo
dove notare il gesto era tutto un gioco
di sguardi e caduta e marina fioraia
marina ascoltava i signori marina
accusava i fiori marina baciava e fiore
marina si nascondeva e si mimetizzava
tre fiori è che questo è stato un
periodo molto
passiamo agli outfit da allora
l'eleganza la classe un colletto che
manco maria antonietta ovviamente
destina nido d'ape che mia mamma mi
rifila va sempre in fino al tipo dieci
anni dove giro così ecco qui un
abbinamento eco molto ricche molto
classe un cappello lecita rifiuti rosso
di me e di nuovo trittico ri perché con
quei fiori c'erano sempre questo
fantastico a ospiti invece uno dei
preferiti
era una maria fashion blogger erano
marina che ci credeva molto qui è molto
chiara ferragni una posa da fashion
blogger c che abbiamo molto notare le
mutandine verdi che spuntano un tocco di
classe non indifferente
su questo outfit mi soffermerei perché
era ispirato da una persona persona che
io stimo molto una leggenda di anni 90
la zingara se lo so insinuava floris
moris come siamo non si sa ma faceva
questa cosa fa aveva delle carte lei e
va su e diceva
la luna nera un alunno e la girava così
e c'era il terrore negli occhi di tutti
i bambini perché nella luna nera arrivo
la morte non si è mai capito che come la
skoda senza una nera ma metteva molto
angolata ansia e in questo look ispirato
proprio a lei
continuiamo con questo outfit che
definirei a metà tra l'osceno è
improponibile molto anni 90 ecco una
gonna di velluto a costine un top con
una spruzzata di orientale di buddismo
di fiorellini di cnet non c'è tutto
tutto l'oriente rapito in questo trovo
questo è oriente
abbiamo chiuso periodo outfit e passiamo
le ultime cose condivide con due sono le
foto che le vite buffet ma perché
sinceramente non c'era un mood che cosa
farà il gruppo acs abbiamo la foto di
marina con la sua prima e ultima
macchina ad ora spendere due parole per
questa foto per che cosa è successo
quella macchinina mi è stato regalato
troppo un'altra macchina però mi piaceva
perché vuole quella di rosalie minimi a
sant'agata la macchina un po tipo le
mans
ma che cosa io voglio rosa mi regalano
la sua macchina ci gira i due giorni in
cortile dopo di che la cantonale
coloriamo sempre macchine da quel
momento infatti è finita una marina
molto molto gentile dolce una marina che
non ha per niente voglia
fare la ribelle morina sì possiamo
definire ribelle dal 1990 fine il tocco
proprio cioè la chiamerei la foto cioè
non può essere definite sono con la foto
[Musica]
la domanda è
perché non avevo le mutante 2 perché
questa bambina non so chi sia il numero
il col
3 perché stavo mostrando il didietro a
chi mi stava facendo la foto non so se
davanti c'era che la stessa prospettiva
ma comunque ogni volta che lo vedo mi
chiedo che cosa avevo in mente e per
quel motivo questo gesto così consob ha
forse uno o due anni
ecco poco chiuso a questo dramma is live
ha risposto non so come chiamarlo ci
penserò quando si velocità e se vi è
piaciuto il video ovviamente iscrivetevi
al canale essere una cosa tanto seguite
vissuti di social facebook slam musicali
e insegnerà e sei piaciuto il video
magari costare la seconda parte con
delle foto un po più tipo liceo medie
perché siamo rimasti qui sul sull'età un
po più basso come prassi quindi se
volete anche il seconda parte
scrivete voi scrivete nei commenti
[Musica]
ciao